[Music]
it was a Thursday morning
I just taken the last few sips of my
coffee now lukewarm from sitting out too
long
I sent off the last email and was about
to start in on the real work for the day
but first decided to take a quick break
and check Facebook so I open up Facebook
and amidst an endless stream of recent
engagement photos and birthdays I saw a
photo that was very different from the
rest you might have seen it to do with a
photo of a tiny Syrian boy his limp body
washed up on the shore of Turkey now up
until this point for me the Syrian
refugee crisis had just been a news
story
it was stories of deaths and bombings
and things completely unrelated to my
life with this photo change that this
photo put a face to the conflict there
is a three-year-old boy named Alan Kurdi
who had died because of this conflict
now I'm not an expert on Syria I'm not
someone who dedicated my recent life's
work to bringing relief to this conflict
I'm like most of you here I'm someone
who hears the statistics 12 million
people have rooted from their homes
500,000 people dead I hear those stats
what I still find it incredibly
difficult to empathize in a meaningful
way and that's the problem today our
empathy for humanitarian crises is out
of shape and lazy it's time to Train it
we can build a daily routine to train
our empathy from sleeping to waking to
action just like a morning routine our
empathy routine begins in a trance
unaware of the world around us
I call this the empathy sleepwalks next
we must rouse our emotion to wake up
from that sleep walk and I call this the
empathy alarm clock and finally one for
awake we must take action throughout the
day this is empathy exercise we are all
in an empathy sleepwalk at some point or
another there's a saying one death is a
tragedy one million is a statistic when
we hear the death tolls in Syria 500,000
people it's just an abstract number that
number passes in one ear and out the
other just as if we were sleepwalking
research support this idea that we don't
work well in the abstract in a recent
study based on the Iraq war participants
were told there were either 15
casualties in a battle or 500 but in
both cases participants demonstrated
zero difference in emotional response
between the two the abstract nature of
those numbers walls participants into a
sleepwalk unable to perceive difference
in magnitude or weight now being in this
sleep walk in and of itself is not a bad
thing I start our empathy routine here
because sometimes we need to rest and
recharge in order for our empathy to be
most effective sometimes we need an
escape from the endless statistics and
abstract numbers that modern media sends
our way but it's not okay to stay in the
sleep block state forever just as with
every morning routine we must be able to
wake up and face the day so how do we do
that how do we set off the alarm clock
to startle us awake let's go back to
that research study well there is no
difference between the 15 and 500 when
those numbers are accompanied by images
of the fallen soldiers
the emotional response spiked
dramatically for the 500 this highlights
the concepts at concrete images not the
abstract numbers they represent can wake
up our emotion we said earlier that the
500,000 deaths in Syria feels abstract
so now let's make that concrete to wake
all of us up here what if I were to tell
you that number would be the same as if
everyone in this room and all of our
classmates outside and every alumni
that's ever graduated from the GSB
dating back to the skooled inception was
decimated and now multiply that by 15
the challenge before us is to seek out
and create these alarm clock moments I
ask you to speak out independent news
sources that move beyond those abstract
numbers as we just did check out the
Syrian campaign for another opportunity
to wake up your emotion and then share
those moments to create the alarm clocks
for those around you the retweet of a
photojournalism article or the
screenshot of your donation to a relief
organization like the white helmet or
the low-key notes that you give to your
peers on the crisis these are the
concrete moments or the alarm clocks if
you will that can wake up the empathy of
an entire community once our empathy is
awake the last step is to exercise it
empathy is like a muscle for many of us
our empathy may be like our deltoids
it's kind of this random shoulder muscle
that you don't engage often and to
exercise that you really have to go out
of your way but the goal is to exercise
our empathy like our quadriceps they're
constantly engaged for standing and
walking and you don't have to think
about it it's second nature
we can learn this lesson from another
refugee crisis where modest exercise of
empathy muscles had tremendous lasting
impact during the Vietnam War there's an
American family called the trip priests
in Long Island they were a middle-class
family of 11
the father retired fireman turned
security guard now with 11 mouths to
feed you might think that the trip
region has that much extra to give but
they exercise our empathy every day
so when Vietnamese refugees began
arriving in America the trip frees
empathy muscles were primed to help as
easily as walking they opened up their
home to a young family of three refugees
the trip reach ildren never complained
about doubling or even tripling up in
their bedrooms they didn't think twice
about how they fit 14 people around an
already overflowing dinner table each
night they just huddled together with
smiling faces and open arms to share
their love with complete strangers
empathy for them was muscle memory
the trip fries are a beautiful example
of the ripple effect that empathy
exercise can have I know because the
family of three refugees that they saved
with my own family here's my brother and
my mom and dad it's now 40 years later
and were again confronted with a tragic
refugee crisis what have we learned the
trip we taught us that we have to
exercise our empathy every day even in
small ways to make this a part of your
routine pair with an action you already
take when you call your family to check
in a luxury many Syrians don't have take
two extra minutes to call your
representatives to influence their
stance on US refugee policy or when you
pay your monthly gym bill set aside 10%
to donate to a relief organization like
the International Rescue Committee I'm
soon with this daily training our
empathy muscles can do the heavy lifting
without breaking a sweat
and the idea of tackling something as
immense as Syria or as impossible as
sitting 14 people around a tiny dinner
table no longer will seem that daunting
I want to leave you with one thought
it's that we can train our empathy to be
a powerful tool follow this routine from
resting with the empathy sleep walk wake
it up with an empathy alarm clock and
then strengthen it with small actions
every day and put the exercise we sleep
we wake we exercise so the next time
you're confronted with a heartbreaking
photo of a little boy you'll be ready to
help because it's now just a part of
your routine
[Applause]
[Music]